Tiffany Boppity one two and two can
everybody hear me
move over mal there's a new hero in town
and her name is Carson
you know the costume designer
extraordinaire who created the very
platform boots you walk on it's clear to
see that you're a hero Cara you are
raising the bar when it comes to style
attitude and charisma we loved every
single one of your outfits so we hope
you don't take it personally but it's
time to play the ranking game hmm
every single a K&D BK was decked out
from head to toe but a certain V case
outfit stood out to us the most washing
tell the end to find out which of your
favorite descendants characters made it
to the top three she's glamorous she's
fabulous she's chic but yet she's still
very edgy and sophisticated Disney
descendants released a wardrobe video on
August 5th and our stars got the chance
to describe the cast costumes in detail
Sarah Jeffery commented on how sleek and
glamorous the costumes are Pippi kazar
decked out in punkish leather suits that
are colorful and unique
although the cast might be sporting
sophisticated looks in descendants 3
their costumes are a lot edgy ER and
uniquely tailored this time around the
three cool is jam-packed with colorful
outfits that promise a happy ending at
every turn so who's ready to find out
which characters made it into the top 10
Harry hook first on the list is Harry
hook the devilish charmer from the Isle
of the Lost we catch our first glimpse
of Harry when he jumps through the
barrier with Gil his outfit is
predominantly black but he's got a few
textures going on leather suede silk
it's all up for the taking Harry's
wearing a sleeveless cloak that's got a
hook embroidered on the back it's lined
with red silk and has leather straps
fasten it together
we're digging Harry's gothic pirate
vibes J then there's day who is totally
rockin his Punk biker look his outfit
looks like a cross between the yellow
and red Power Rangers but it's on a
spectrum of its own but
end of the movie J changes into a more
laid-back outfit his costume screams son
of Jafar and we're sure his dad would be
proud J looks sophisticated and
clean-cut
we totally loved Jade's glow up from
descendants one two descendants three
Carlos in eighth place is Carlos de Vil
unlike his mother Carlos prefers a
clean-cut fur free look he's wearing a
light gray leather one-piece it's
decorated with black and red accents
that would make his mother proud
Carlos his big red combat boots are edgy
and cool at the end of the movie we see
Carlos sporting a whole new look
he looks classy in his black trousers
skeleton-like blazer and white dress
shirt and must I forget those red gloves
dizzy Jermaine Dizzy's always had a
stylish look so we were a little
surprised to see her sporting an
oversized dress and bonnet at the
beginning of the film but even then she
managed to slay her look she gets a
wardrobe change before heading over to
Aragon and we can't get over her costume
Dizzy's got aqua blue flowers in her
hair
puffy olive green sleeves and a black
dress with colorfully embroidered
flowers her look is young and vibrant
just like her Celia facile ear coming in
one step ahead of dizzy is her best pal
Celia facile ear every single one of
Celia's outfit speaks true to who she is
she's a total daddy's girl so it comes
as no surprise that she's dressed like
dr. facile ear she's got her little top
hat on and she's wearing a black dress
with striped sleeves and colorful
fabrics Celia and her outfit are a match
made in New Orleans Haiti's coming in at
fifth place is the Lord of the
underworld you shouldn't have come
Hades has one of the most wicked outfits
ever he's decked out in black leather
has the coolest blue hair and his vest
is studded and vintage looking Hades
looks like an underground rock star he's
wearing big combat boots and gives his
daughters a run for their money
now coming in at fourth place is the
purple Queen of auradon booty now in
fourth place wasn't easy but once we
show you who we chose for our top three
your
to agree with us Mao has so many awesome
looks throughout the film she's probably
the one to have the most outfits but in
our books mouths engagement dress takes
the cake a purple dragon flying over a
field of green can be spotted on Mao's
dress she's also wearing dragon wings on
her shoulders smell is every bit her
mother's daughter in this dress
Eevee in third place is the blueberry
princess Eevee has one of the most
classic looks in descendants three she
looks gorgeous confident radiant and put
together every one of Evie's outfits are
a sight for sore eyes
but if we had to choose one we'd go with
her VK outfit Evie's rocking everything
from her tiara to her leather skirt to
her combat boots
she looks 100% - wicked Audrey for sorry
Audrey
you didn't quite make first place but
hey you did come in two spots ahead of
now so that's saying something you're a
villain look was to die for
from your vibrant pink and purple hair
to your embroidered sleeves and pink
suede pants the queen of mean is spear
sleep a tional uma let's give it up for
uma guys this ocean travelling VK
snagged the first spot by a long shot
all of whom as costumes are cool
refreshing and unique but we absolutely
fell in love with her very last look uma
looks like the princess of the aisle in
her aqua blue dress leather corset and
bandana and that's a wrap which outfits
were your favorites tell us in the
comments give this video a big thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe to the
things thanks for watching we'll see you
next time
[Music]